we're entering an era in which our  enemies can make it look like anyone is  saying anything at any point in time  even if they would never say those  things so for instance they could have  me say things like I don't know kill  monger was right or Ben Carson is in the  sunken place or how about this simply  President Trump is a total and complete  [ __ ] now  you see I would never say these things  at least not in a public address but  someone else would someone like Jordan  Peele this is a dangerous time moving  forward we need to be more vigilant with  what we trust from the internet that's a  time when we need to rely on trusted  news sources they sound basic but how we  move forward age of information is gonna  be the difference between whether we  survive or whether we become some kind  of fucked-up dystopia thank you and stay  wolf [ __ ]